was the time period for
the observing
uh of a fast and abstaining from the
things which break the fasts which
you've already mentioned always the same
since the beginning of time or for the
Muslims as far as the Muslims are
concerned when the first time it was
mentioned in the Quran in surah bakar
chapter 2 was 183 which I mentioned
earlier that fasting was fur at that
time the Muslims used to fast 3 days in
a
month. Later on when the verse of the
Quran was revealed of surah Bakar
chapter number two verse number 185
which I quoted the second time that
Ramadan is the month in which the Quran
was
revealed and in it is guidance for the
humankind
and in it as signs for guidance and
judgment right and wrong. So the Muslims
when they witnessed this month they
should fast. So then it became fur for
the Muslim to fast the complete month of
Ramna. First it was only 3 days every
month then it became one full month only
the month of Ramadan. As far as the
things that break the fast are concerned
one of the things that break the fast it
is sexual intercourse even with your
wife.
So previously when this verse of surah
bakar chapter 2 verse number 185 was
revealed it was not mentioned in detail.
So the Muslims at that time they used to
abstain from sexual intercourse
approaching their wives for the full
month of Ramadan even during the day and
night and it was very difficult for many
of the Muslims many of the Sahabas and
that reminds me of a quotation or
incident which is mentioned in one of
the commentaries of the Quran. If you
read the comment of the Quran, volume
number two, page number
210, it mentions there that may Allah be
pleased with
him. Once after speaking with the
prophet late in the night, he comes back
home and he has the urge to sleep with
his wife and he spends the time with his
wife and he has sexually intercourse
with his wife. In the morning when he
gets up, he feels very bad. He's
ashamed. He immediately goes to the
prophet and he says that I asked pardon
from Allah and his messenger for what
I've done and my soul was attracted
towards my wife and I had a relationship
with my wife in the night. Is there any
way that I can be pardoned or is there
any way that I can escape? So the
prophet said, "Is it true that you
actually did this?" He said yes prophet.
Prophet was shocked. How could I um may
Allah be pleased with him could do a
thing at that time it was prohibited. He
said yes Allah's messenger I did it is
anywhere I can be pardoned. So the
prophet said no one besides Allah can
give the command and alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah immediately after this the
verse of surah bakar chapter number two
verse number 187 was revealed. It says
that permitted to
you during the nights of the fast is
approaching your
wives. And then it
says that they are your garments and you
are the garments. That means your wives
are your garments and you are the
garments of your wife. And Allah says
that we know what you do secretly in the
night but Allah forgive you and from now
onwards you can approach your wives
during the nights of the fast and you
can eat and drink till the white thread
of dawn is differentiated from the black
thread. So when this verse was revealed
later on surakra 2 verse number 97 then
the rules were a bit more relaxed that
they could have sexual relationship with
their wife during the nights but during
the day they have to abstain.
Furthermore, as far as eating was
concerned, previously before Surah Bakar
chapter 2 verse number 187 was revealed,
the Muslims could eat and drink after
the sunsets. But the moment they sleep,
after that they can't eat. Then they can
eat only the next day after sunsets. So
there's the incident of one of the
Sabas may Allah be pleased with him. He
worked very hard and he was fasting.
And when it was time to break the fast,
he comes home and he tells his wife that
I want to have some food. So wife says
that there's no food in the house. I'll
just get it from outside. And she goes
out to get food. Now because he was
tired working the full day, by the time
the wife comes back, he goes to sleep.
When the wife comes back to the house,
she sees the husband has gone to sleep.
So now she says finish. Once he's gone
to sleep, he can't eat. So that night he
could not eat the next day he had to
fast and by evening the next day he
faints and the people go to the prophet
that this is what happened because once
you sleep you can't eat later on this
verse was which I said earlier surah
bakar chapter 2 verse number 97 which
says besides approaching your wives at
night you can eat and drink till the
white thread of dawn is differentiated
from the black thread. So then the rules
that we follow today that fasting means
that you have to abstain from food and
drink and nourishment as well as from
sexual
intercourse right from dawn until sunset
and having the intention that we have to
be Allah subhanaa tala. It's an act of
worship. So this is the history how we
finally got this. It's very interesting
and uh I think we've got it easy as
compared to Sahab. Alhamdulillah.